you can figure that how you put that in
the context is what through dealing with
right now with this little rocket
starting with the lane wide open that's
a benefit of small ball wing players and
guards that can penetrate just as much
as you see Russell Westbrook and also
James Harden
- nice three-point shot there so trying
to keep guys out of the lane on both
ends of the ball just keep your eye on
what the league is doing in regards to
playing small ball and Houston fits
right in that mix Covington 4-3 the
newcomer buries a triple because it's in
his numbers of more portly the
confidence that he exudes has gotten
them to that all-star type level
step-back three for harden is true it's
an early three first quarter action
second of our doubleheader TNT Tuesday
night hello
who was traded to Atlanta but he said
this is the way potential kids buy for
rocket celtics Marcus smart and a great
defensive play and their victory at OKC
Canela blocked met at the rim by hard
knees and that's that swarming defense
from a small lineup to be able to
recover to take that layup away one
offensive rebound in this first quarter
Westbrook backing down Wanamaker flurry
of mousse goes up at over tights
oh.what basket by Russell Westbrook
shouldn't be a surprise to those who
watch the rockets that basically the
recipients the russell westbrook could
able to isolate and get to the basket
take it on Marcus Martin those two have
had some battle James Harden it's the
best way to beat it is when he throws it
out to double-team make a quick play to
drive in a pass it do I have the
advantage against the defense or but
when he goes one-on-one Wanamaker's to
Tatum ball moves well with Boston when
they are at their men's now
Steele excuse me Westbrook with the
steal and the rest all the way in
smart blocks him but a foul when this
Boston team gets rolling offensive loop
Westbrook on the attack after the made
basket
Westbrook caught him off guard rockets
within two we're approaching a loved one
minute mark here of this first half
and the front we don't have size inside
you can't load up on Westbrook when he's
attacking the basket harden and
Westbrook
Westbrook easy austin has won seven
straight they have a game on Thursday
his James Harden gives it to Tucker
coming out of the halftime locker room
it easy all tied at 49 just underway in
the second half second of our
doubleheader tonight and Russell with a
mid-range jumper that is true first five
and a half minutes of the game was clean
only one turnover they were making their
shots they've got ten turnovers now
Westbrook on the drive easy finger roll
at the basket you winning a championship
fast forward to Mike D'Antoni even in
Phoenix small lineups one out not a
championship that proved that it could
work so that's not the first time that
we've seen it with getting shots up left
and right and teams had to try to match
up with it no that was a struggling team
back then as Hart yet gets inside and
gets the layup for the Rockets did a
better job of rotating the basketball
and the ball moves faster able to get
that shot in the corner harden answers
have more freedom of movement and taking
the big man out the game who's to say
that it doesn't have the chance to make
an impact hard another step back three
this time with smart art of it James
Harden
[Music]
Hayward the tallest player on the floor
for Boston at six seven shot clock at
four
smart on Harden harden fire seven three
throws coming up James Harden all-star
starter on point in quarter number three
James Harden at that big third quarter
at 19 in the quarter Westbrook on the
tee gets a step and scores
foul on smart the issue here is that
that is a hook right down the backside
so smart does have a a complaint here
but the challenge is when Russell is
able to players to take open looks with
confidence
harden
got another one too Tatum he'll be
pairing up with LeBron James here's
Westbrook on the drive lamp is good for
Westbrook next Wednesday the first
practice after the all-star break Walker
misses a three here comes Westbrook
one on four and he'll score Russell
Westbrook
in transition what do you do do I step
up against Russell Russell Westbrook has
been a problem for Houston this year
they've lost 11 games when they've had a
lead of 10 or more in the corner it's
house he's got it a big shot Daniel
House says Mike D'Antoni we got to get
the steals we got to make it hard as
Westbrook flying to the basket goes with
the reverse shot him out of a cannon
coming to now for three what brown fell
down his ankle he's limping off on the
attack Westbrook gives it up house
finishes and Brown is hurt took himself
right out of the play team feisty on the
King Ethelred making it a little bit
uncomfortable for the subsistence even
hardly scores it all the Carson Edwards